this is Jake the dog this is much better
quick um so okay they're quick some of
this story fit what's the crowd on is
not so slowly very quickly going crazy
very much like the Ice King he's even
getting his voice and he's trying to
protect everybody but the crown is also
consuming him you know it very much like
whatever with the Ice King while all
that is going on Jake is still in that
cube with P prismo prismo uh and later
on oh well yeah yeah and later on the
cosmic al becomes sandwiches with our
name we see this cosmic owl it's a I'm
sure that you ever hear him talk before
only time when he said well I don't
girls like cuz you're a sociopath yeah
that's right I mean you know there's so
much mystery to the cosmic owl we don't
know adventures to see him come in with
games
why are you together with that
singularity relaxing gets and all while
on the TV you see all the insanity going
on with Finn and these three guys are
just hanging it's it's really funny
really I love how the prismo my shadow
is in the hot tub like it dan even yeah
like be outside the water
oh and so all this madness was going on
and prismo you know tells Jake if he's
gonna make a wish it has to be a good
wish you know it has to have a lot of
detail to it
Jake originally wish for a sandwich
again just showing its I don't think
he's mean I just don't think he knows
better you know it's like maybe a big
sandwich or a small sandwich I don't
know
yeah but finally on the TV screen when
the unmuted he sees like right no I want
I want Finn what everything go back to
normal
uh prismo omits that all his wishes have
an ironic twist like the monkey fall
with
I just love it when somebody just
straight-up admits no no all the wishes
have an ironic boy massage well is it
gonna be a dirty man
remember that man from his family dead
go that was all great so finally prismo
convinces him of the correct wish to get
everything back to normal everything
goes back to normal the jewels all go
back to where they're supposed to go and
I'm even trying to remember what the
last like why Dorsey was well the
pickles the answer he gets the pickles
they's just like you know if you ever
let Hank give you a call it's just like
yeah he needs a girlfriend that's it and
I was definitely really funny it was
much better than the last episode uh
tying back to the season finale that led
up to this though this dose of what I
thought it was gonna be I mean it's I I
really I like this episode a lot
honestly like it I think it's actually
very very clever and very funny and and
the deliveries are great and all that
stuff but yeah I think for what was
built up it's still what still funny ads
clever it still doesn't deliver what I
thought they were really building up
with the tone and the atmosphere and the
just how much weight was in that series
finale well I mean you've got I remember
you where it's a great balance of drama
and comedy then after that we have the
Lynch which had a great balance of
comedy and also terror if you will or
like the whole episode was kind of like
it was a good episode it had a few
little jokes in there where you were
chuckling but then it's over with you're
like wait a minute I wasn't laughing
that much that's really embedded you
know then we get Finn the human which
was very kind of dry yeah it's kind of
like there's very little comedy for the
most part in all that stuff let me get
Jake the dog which was comedy comedy
comedy comedy comedy with a few dramatic
parts tossed in yeah and it was for me I
I felt one Jay
with just being an asshole I mean you're
right I think he didn't know any better
but the entire time that he comes around
to Evangeline but then again think about
what Jake Finn has to go through you
know he has to go through all the
suffering before his friend finally
realized that but he could also wish him
back but again I don't know what Jake's
thinking bad side about the fence no I
know it's just for me it's just like I
don't know it just kind of shows the two
opposites that are Finn and Jake you
know Finn is always thinking about
others without thinking he just kind of
jumps in and does things for others Jake
doesn't do anything for anyone but
himself
yeah like even helping others he kind of
like I get the feeling the whole way he
got into that it's because he saw oh hey
this kids having fun Finn is like I'll
try to and that's kind of fun
I'll keep doing this you know and like
it's still kind of for his own game it
just it felt with these last two
episodes as a season opener it's so
unbalanced well especially for two
episodes this is one of the few times
where I was actually sort of soaking up
the title it's like you have the Lich
and the you know the big series a season
finale and then Finn the human and the
next one Jake the dog it's like that's
always you know you hear it in the
opening of each one and then it's like
now here's a whole episode called Finn
the human the next one Jake the dogs
like what is this gonna mean what is
this you know gonna be about as just
like their I don't feel like I've
learned any more about them I mean Billy
which is like you know it's even the
title seems a little off it's like this
was your episode to call Finn the human
and this was your episode to call Jake
the dog yeah you know so it's not like
what I saw when I saw a preview for the
movie life don't like the Martin
Lawrence in the Eddie Murphy movie and
I'm just like okay I know it's like
they're going to jail for life and it's
a joke if I'm like that's the movie
called life like come on that's life
you're wasting it on this yeah yeah I
mean I never thought about the titles
that way but yeah like those are great
titles that kind of went to waste yeah
it's like why
I give these titles to these two
episodes I didn't even get it focused
one was all about pen and one's just all
about Jake it kind of like yes I mean
we're still seeing what's going on with
Finn in the back wrap it was just about
him they were lifted on mute the whole
time no I know I know but then you come
around at some point in time again
leaning for me to the whole thing of
Jake doesn't really care about anything
but himself or what's happening
literally in the moment because even
when he does finally pay attention and
decide to say Finn why That's not me
yeah I'm finna start calling someone
else Jake when I hi I'm Jake yeah I
agree
so it's I mean it it's all the same well
what's that why there's no such thing as
an unselfie as I'm selfish charity or
something like that I even charity is
benefitting yourself somehow you know
and you could argue take it's just the
extreme of that but um I mean I kind of
okay even though he did sort of throw me
off to like last and which really his
friends god he's going for a sandwich
but it kind of ties into other stuff
he's talked about before and like I said
it's even though it's like the means of
getting they are not necessarily the
most honorable he still does try it's
best to do what he feels is the right
thing yeah boys I did enjoy the comedy
of it Oh in a way in a way if he wasn't
so self-centered though he wouldn't have
had the time to chill and relax with
shadow dude prismo prismo to the point
where prismo actually got to know him
and liked him enough to help him and
tell him how to fix everything i see you
have a very good point there if you
think about it so in a way and not on
purpose clearly but Jake kind of did
save the day by being an ass wad
you know yeah no exit so yeah but now
it's still done from a selfish reason oh
yeah you know why you're right it does
um I I wanna say but I really like
prismo Jessa Carrie I really like how
actually it's one of those where it's
like I really want to see him come back
and I want to see him and Jake just Hank
there's something some people you can
see you hang out and whatever you're at
a party it's just like oh god can I just
get out of here or something but there's
some people you see hanging out but
there are some people where it's like
you can just enjoy watching them hang
out cuz there's so much fun water like
there's movies I can or whatever TV
shows documentaries whatever where I can
just watch people - people forget watch
these V likes just hear us talk about a
show yeah I would say that's how they
probably more listen to you but well
they have and they come to see your junk
which is quite fabulous she know she
represents all women no 30 Helen - 38:30
Helens agree to the press Helen's agreed
you get killed I see kids about all yes
I well anything no I I know what you're
saying like there's some times you can
kind of just watch you see someone at a
party you're like oh man I can't wait to
hang out with them
and you can just sit there and listen to
them talk or watch them interact with
other people and it's just as enjoyable
as being part of the actual conversation
yeah like something they can even be a
jerk but they're just so interesting you
know right I'm talking about YouTube
right now specifically but yeah he's
right no I'm not sure I don't know what
you want to hang out with the jerk well
no not hang out like it
I guess I am the jerk at the party then
yeah okay for example like Jake was
being very selfish you know you know
time it but we still like watching him
you know we like we like see hits in the
hot tub well his best friend is going
through horrible tortures I got for you
laughs I got a laugh because like I said
I don't I just don't think he knows any
better and it's he still comes around
and I think you could still sort of use
the excuse like he could always use and
I can't use the wish later because he
would still have gotten the sandwich or
enjoy anyway um I I think that's just
kind of like his mindset though I guess
and just everything is sort of for him
but I'm just looking from finished
perspective if Finn actually was in our
position watching these episodes look my
god you're an asshole with you food then
you're always saving me but go away but
he still comes around he still comes
around he doesn't come around
Jake darling yeah prismo that does no no
no no Jake sees like wait a minute I
don't know no this is bad man oh and
yeah looks like don't you want to make
your wish thing it's like yeah yeah I
want a sandwich
Oh didn't you think there's someone else
you should be thinking about I can make
you a sandwich no no but that was early
I'm talking about later no but that's
what I'm saying
even in the beginning prismo knew what
was going on like he knew I was better
it's Bobby yeah well yeah well that's no
crazy but that's even before they hung
out prismo was already telling him
okaying an idiot okay okay okay look let
me say this if at near the end when
prismo is helping him get the wish okay
a Jake who really didn't care about Finn
halfway through that would be I'm for
give me the sandwich you know he still
just the way they have established Jake
and what he's like I get the feeling
halfway through they just be like yeah
the screw Finn or something but because
they still did create a friendship that
even though he's so low on the shallow
totem pole or whatever that it still is
worth going through something that to
him was probably a lot of work and he
was even happy like you know when things
were back to normal and he was like you
know yeah
and he put everything back to normal and
stuff so I don't know it's I do her a
the asshole saves the day yeah pretty
much
so if you don't works out just enough
but I I see where you're coming from to
it it's very very selfish point to start
at him to come from doesn't everybody
have that one friend where you're like
yeah I know he's a dick but you look at
that right now you get the ceiling right
now I'm trying to actually think the
ceilings a dick yeah such a dick it's
made out of dicks yes yes it is yeah
okay I ask you about that you're gonna
not change that no it's kind of nice the
way this yeah I don't you know just like
the changing colors yeah I kind of like
rainbow dicks
yeah whoa wait haven't you ever seen a
Teen Hunger Force the episode the flow
of penises and the dicks it's a
spaceship out of dicks no I missed that
one but were they rainbow yeah and well
I'm the edited version no no they were
so blacked out
no yeah we're doing great with color
though really yeah it's nice I like the
way they my family friendly yeah when
you when you play some music different
colors light up I think that was really
insane my friend hooked that up I don't
know how to do any of that
who's your friend the asshole for I
still can't think of what friend of mine
is oh wait I do now I remember who the
asshole is it's doogie's yeah Oh as much
as I give him crap actually Doug's a
really nice person yeah I'll give you
asshole definitely a nice guy nope he's
the worst well you two in the Knights is
colorful Oh what because we're a couple
more if we were individuals we wouldn't
be cool wouldn't be nice no we
understand with no it's not no I'm
walking away this time not that you
wouldn't be cool is that you're not cool
they gotta get sleeps we have to join
forces yet or to be evil
sad we are we have to join forces like
wonder twin powers act no not twins no
twincest wonderful incest yes
no wonder couple ponies just say
something to end the video thank you bye